This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。欢迎收看Look Back at it播客。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利西。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马尔科姆·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人更重要了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嗨，大家好！
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯为您带来的《艰难成长》。本空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但您是在与一位知其然的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。2023年，美国单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这份特殊的检测报告你篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧精神、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听2%？也就是TWA%。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, you know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. today we're going to talk about something that I think is on a lot of our radars in some capacity. Two of the biggest and I would say most noteworthy elements of our 20s are dating, figuring out that whole side of things and also our experiences with navigating our mental health. I think that those two things really define this period of life more significantly more profoundly
大家好，欢迎回到你的20岁心理学，这是一个探讨我们在20岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，你们都懂的。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20岁时的心理学。今天我们要谈论一个我认为在某种程度上引起了我们很多人关注的话题。我们20岁时最大、也可以说最引人注目的两个元素是约会，弄清楚那一整套事情，以及我们在应对心理健康方面的经历。我认为这两件事确实比其他任何事情都更显著、更深刻地定义了人生的这一阶段
than anything else. They are at the center of a lot of the most life-changing experiences and moments during this chapter of our lives. I think a lot of the biggest revelations we have about who we are and who we want to become come from these two kind of facets. They come from who we're dating, how we're dating our experiences with love and heartbreak and so many other facets. And then also our experiences with coping and coping with how our mind works.
。它们是我们人生这个阶段许多最能改变人生的经历和时刻的核心。我认为，关于我们是谁以及我们想成为什么样的人，我们拥有的许多最大启示都来自于这两个方面。它们来自于我们在和谁约会、我们如何约会、我们对爱与心碎的经历以及许多其他方面。还有我们应对以及如何应对我们大脑运作方式的经历。
and the ways that sometimes it betrays us. I think whilst a lot of us are out there looking for love, looking for connection, for inspiration, for long-term companionship, whatever it is that you're kind of searching for in your dating life, this is also the decade of quite a lot of mental struggle. And I don't want to say suffering, because I don't think that's the right word, but healing maybe and also deep emotional work.
以及它有时如何背叛我们。我认为，虽然我们中的许多人都在寻找爱、寻找连接、寻找灵感、寻找长期伴侣，无论你在约会生活中寻找什么，这同时也是一个充满相当多心理挣扎的十年。我不想说痛苦，因为我觉得那不是正确的词，但也许是疗愈，还有深刻的情感工作。
I think there's no denying the, evidence, the research that 18 to 9 to like 29 year olds have the largest incidence rate of mental health symptoms, primarily anxiety and depression, than any other age group. We see it over and over again in studies all around the world, young people, 20 something year olds, they're really doing it tough when it comes to their mental health. And whilst that is going on, we are also expected to make that big transition into kind of what an adult should look like. And we're meant to show people that we're growing up, that we're progressing, that they don't need to worry about us. You know, we're hitting the adult milestones. Part of that is dating,
我认为无可否认的是，证据和研究表明，18岁到9岁直到29岁左右的人群，其心理健康症状（主要是焦虑和抑郁）的发病率比任何其他年龄组都要高。我们在世界各地的研究中一次又一次地看到这一点，年轻人，20出头的人，他们在心理健康方面真的过得很艰难。在这种情况发生的同时，我们也被期望实现向成年人样子的重大过渡。我们要向人们展示我们正在长大，我们正在进步，他们不需要担心我们。你知道，我们正在达到成年人的里程碑。其中一部分就是约会，
is having a relationship, is meeting people. And what I don't think anybody is talking about is how mental health and dating really interact. That relationship really needs to be explored in both directions because dating is honestly it's such a vulnerable experience it's so intimate you're basically sitting in front of a person and saying please like me for who i am maybe there's a future here please accept me but also you know it's okay if you don't like i don't want to get too close to you like it's it's this whole i think kind of mental maze and our mental health is going to impact how we date how we go about meeting you people how those experiences will affect us.
就是建立恋爱关系，就是结识新朋友。而我认为没有人真正在讨论的是心理健康和约会是如何真正相互作用的。这种关系确实需要在两个方向上进行探索，因为约会老实说是一段非常脆弱的经历，它是如此私密，你基本上是坐在一个人面前说：“请喜欢我本来的样子，这里也许有未来，请接受我。”但同时，你知道，如果你不喜欢也没关系，我不想和你靠得太近，这就像，我认为这是一种精神迷宫，我们的心理健康将影响我们的约会方式，我们结识新朋友的方式，以及这些经历将如何影响我们。
And dating will also simultaneously impact our mental health, the rejection, the heartbreak, the ups and downs. That really does something to our coping skills, to our mood, our confidence, our overall sense of emotional stability. And I think that's really important to recognize. I also think part of the conversation around dating and mental health has to do with the partners of people with mental health struggles, and what is it that they need to understand
与此同时，约会也会对我们的心理健康产生影响，拒绝、心碎、起伏。这确实对我们的应对能力、情绪、自信心、整体情感稳定感产生了一定影响。我认为认识到这一点非常重要。我还认为，围绕约会和心理健康的部分对话与心理健康挣扎者的伴侣有关，他们需要了解什么？
that maybe isn't communicated? You know, the things that people need from a relationship is, you know, it's going to differ. It's going to differ based on things like preferences and attachment styles and past relationships, all of those things, but also based on where we are at mentally. If you are anxious, you might require, you know, more reassurance from your partner.
也许没有沟通的是什么？你知道，人们从恋爱关系中需要的东西是不同的。它将根据偏好、依恋类型和过去的恋爱关系等因素而有所不同，但也将根据我们精神上的处境而有所不同。如果你感到焦虑，你可能需要伴侣更多的安慰。
If you're prone to depressive episodes, you might self-isolate. You might push people away. And it doesn't mean that you don't care about them, that you don't want connection, that you are not deserving of connection. I just think that it is something that is part of kind of like, not to sound cheesy, but our journey.
如果你容易出现抑郁发作，你可能会自我孤立。你可能会把人推开。这并不意味着你不关心他们，你不想建立连接，你就不配拥有连接。我只是认为这是某种程度上的一部分，听起来可能有点老套，但这是我们旅程的一部分。
And it's part of how we find people who accept us for who we truly are. So I want to talk about it today. I want to talk about every side of this connection, how everything interacts in this way. And I think more importantly, how we can have both. how we can date successfully without letting it harm our most precious resource, which is our mental health. How do we put up boundaries? How do we have hard conversations with the people we're seeing around what we need? How do we approach the things that maybe we want to hide from? How do we stop trauma bonding with people or letting people take advantage of us?
这也是我们寻找真正接受我们本来面目的人的一部分。所以今天我想谈谈它。我想谈谈这种联系的各个方面，一切是如何以这种方式相互作用的。我认为更重要的是，我们如何鱼与熊掌兼得。我们如何在不损害我们最宝贵资源（即心理健康）的情况下成功约会。我们如何设立界限？我们如何与我们正在交往的人就我们需要什么进行艰难的对话？我们如何面对那些我们可能想要逃避的事情？我们如何停止与他人进行创伤绑定或让别人占我们的便宜？
How do we kind of cope with dealing with simultaneously the crazy world of dating whilst also taking care of ourselves? and taking care of our mental health. So we're going to talk about all of it, all the research, all the psychology, all the science, and so much more. So let's get into it. I want to start off by talking about how our mental health impacts how we date, how it changes the way that we date, our behavioral patterns, our attitudes towards dating. I think mental health is not a one-size-fits-all kind of concept.
我们如何在应付疯狂的约会世界的同时，照顾好自己并照顾好我们的心理健康？所以我们要讨论这一切，所有的研究、所有的心理学、所有的科学以及更多内容。让我们切入正题吧。我想从探讨我们的心理健康如何影响我们的约会方式、它如何改变我们的约会方式、我们的行为模式、我们的约会态度开始。我认为心理健康不是一种“一刀切”的概念。
we can't just slap a label on everyone who could possibly have a diagnosis that falls into the DSM and call it mental health. I think different conditions are going to have a different impact when it comes to dating. And the main ones I really want to look at are really depression and anxiety. I think those have the highest prevalence. But there's also a lot to be said about the interactions between like ADHD and BPD and dating. One of the biggest things that underpins all conditions, all mental health, conditions is though, I think, the experience of stigma that really persists to this day,
我们不能只是给每个可能符合DSM诊断标准的人贴上标签，然后称之为心理健康。我认为不同的病症在约会时会产生不同的影响。我真正想看的主要是抑郁症和焦虑症。我认为这些的患病率最高。但关于多动症（ADHD）和边缘型人格障碍（BPD）与约会之间的相互作用，也有很多话要说。不过，我认为支撑所有病症、所有心理健康状况的最重要因素之一，是至今仍然存在的污名化体验，
we know that stigma shows up in the world. And if it shows up in the world, it's going to show up in the people that we will meet. Maybe the people we will date. It will show up in the people we talk to. As unfortunate and sad as that is, and not everyone has the dialogue that perhaps we're having to understand that really it's on a reflection of who someone is. It doesn't say anything about their worth. So I think that's one of the primary things we have to navigate. How do we have those open conversations around mental health with people that we're dating? When do we tell people? Do we tell people? What do we say? How do we respond when someone doesn't have a good response and they let us down when they kind of reveal a part of themselves that like isn't willing to accept this?
我们知道污名化在世界上是存在的。如果它存在于世界上，它就会出现在我们将要遇到的人身上。也许是我们约会的人。它会出现在我们交谈的人身上。尽管这是不幸和悲伤的，而且并不是每个人都有我们可能正在进行的对话，去理解这其实只是对一个人是谁的反映，它并不说明任何关于他们价值的事情。所以我认为这是我们必须应对的主要事情之一。我们如何与我们约会的人就心理健康进行这些公开对话？我们什么时候告诉别人？我们要告诉别人吗？我们说什么？当某人的反应不好并让我们失望时，当他们暴露出自己不愿接受这一事实的那一面时，我们该如何回应？
Especially if it's someone that you're getting serious with. I want to touch on that just a little bit later on. Firstly, let's kind of break down what it is about conditions that may make dating different for different people who have some kind of experience with mental health. Depression is, I was about to say depression is a good place to start, but, and I know that sounds so terrible, but let's start there. Let's start there. Depression, I think, I know, makes it hard to do anything. It is one of the primary underlying facts about this condition. It makes it hard for you to be excited about anything in life, you know, let alone a random stranger you've met on a dating app, let alone the possibility of having to meet new people and tell them your favorite color and let them get to know you.
特别是如果那是你正在认真对待的人。我稍后会谈到这一点。首先，让我们来剖析一下，病情究竟是什么，可能会让有心理健康经历的不同人经历不同的约会。抑郁症是，我正要说抑郁症是一个很好的起点，但是，我知道这听起来太糟糕了，但我们就从那里开始吧。我们就从那里开始。我知道，抑郁症让做任何事都变得很困难。这是这种病情的主要根本事实之一。它让你对生活中的任何事情都很难感到兴奋，更不用说在约会软件上遇到的一个陌生人了，更不用说去结识新朋友并告诉他们你最喜欢的颜色并让他们了解你的可能性了。
I think depression also causes us to self-isolate at times. It means that we have less energy occasionally to put energy into the early stages of dating, into going on dates into putting ourselves out there. It's really hard, I think, and important to acknowledge that it's going to be different if you're someone who has these episodes of just not feeling like the world is a great place. And maybe your response to that is to go silent, is to self-isolate. During those episodes, I do feel like it's, like, everything stops. And that can be hard for the people that we're dating to understand. We might end up accidentally. ghosting someone, maybe icing them out. And sometimes people don't understand that. And that's not
我认为抑郁症有时也会导致我们自我孤立。这意味着我们偶尔会有较少的精力投入到约会的早期阶段，投入到约会中，投入到向世界展示自己中。我认为，如果你是那种经常觉得世界不是个好地方的人，并且也许你对此的反应是沉默、是自我孤立，那么承认这一点会有所不同，这真的很艰难也很重要。在这些发作期间，我确实觉得，就像，一切都停止了。我们约会的人可能很难理解这一点。我们可能最终会不小心ghost（人间蒸发）某人，也许把他们晾在一边。有时人们不理解这一点。这不是
something that we can redeem ourselves from. Or we let go of good connections because we honestly just don't have the mental bandwidth to maintain them. I think also depression has this awful habit of making us feel like we are not good people because we're not showing up in the way that people expect us to. Let me talk about that a little bit more. I think like when we imagine dating, especially in our 20s, it is this like image of like fun and excitement and like ecstasy and like everything is new and amazing. We're having the best experiences and we're meeting people. But sometimes you just don't feel like a fun person. You just don't feel like you have the space to hold those experiences. And that can make us feel like because
我们可以自我救赎的事情。或者我们放弃了美好的连接，因为老实说，我们根本没有维持它们的精神带宽。我认为抑郁症还有一个可怕的习惯，那就是让我们觉得自己不是好人，因为我们的表现没有达到人们的期望。让我再多谈谈这一点。我想，当我们想象约会时，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，它是一个充满乐趣、兴奋和狂喜的画面，一切都是新鲜和惊人的。我们有最好的经历，我们正在结识新朋友。但有时你就是觉得自己不像个有趣的人。你只是觉得自己没有空间来容纳这些经历。这会让我们觉得，因为
we're not having the same experiences that everyone else is, because we are struggling with something deeper, that we are the problem. We turn to a point of a lot of self-shame. And one of the real big kind of negative self-talk points that I see, we tell ourselves, one of the things we often say is, like, I'm lucky that this person even likes me because of what I'm going through. They're going to get bored of me because I'm not as fun, because I have this part of me that maybe is harder to accept. And I think that that makes it really hard to be vulnerable and to put ourselves out there. Because when we are letting someone see us for who we truly are, those dark sides included, sometimes it's hard to believe that someone will love us for that. That's one element of it.
我们没有经历和其他人一样的生活，因为我们在与更深层的东西作斗争，所以我们才是问题所在。我们转向了充满自我羞愧的地步。我看到的一个非常大的负面自我对话点，我们告诉自己，我们经常说的一句话是：“鉴于我的遭遇，这个人甚至喜欢我，我真是太幸运了。他们会对我感到厌倦，因为我没那么有趣，因为我身上有这部分可能更难以接受的地方。”我认为这使得我们很难敞开心扉并展现自己。因为当我们让某人看到我们真实的自我（包括那些黑暗面）时，有时很难相信会有人因此而爱我们。这是其中的一个要素。
I think one of the elements behind why it's hard to put yourself out there. But another, I think, unintended impact or experience that I think is something that a lot of people who are struggling with mental health have is the need to overshare in order to do. justify our behavior or our experience, almost like we need to warn people of what they can expect. And I think that that can really lead us to maybe being too vulnerable too soon. And I want to clarify what that means, because I'm not saying that if you struggle with depression or anxiety, like that's a secret that you need to keep to yourself. No, I think that you should be really open about it. But I think it's also a natural tendency for us to want to create closeness with
我认为这是为什么很难展现自己背后的原因之一。但我认为，另一个意想不到的影响或经历，也是许多正在与心理健康作斗争的人所经历的，那就是为了证明我们的行为或经历是合理的，而过度分享的需要，几乎就像我们需要警告人们他们可以期待什么一样。我认为这确实会导致我们可能过早地过于脆弱。我想澄清这意味着什么，因为我并不是说如果你患有抑郁症或焦虑症，这是一个需要保守的秘密。不，我认为你应该对此持非常开放的态度。但我认为这也是我们的自然倾向，即想要与
someone and that can cause us to tell them perhaps elements of our experience, elements of our journey that we're revealing too soon and it's causing us to become attached too quickly. Almost because, like I said, we feel like this person needs to be prepared. Like we are this like this thing that like if we don't tell them now, they'll they'll be like surprised. They'll think we tricked them into falling in love. Like it's just, I think, a real negative mental spiral. Like I said, it's not to say that you shouldn't be vulnerable. But I think something that we need to be aware of if you are someone who is dating with mental health is perhaps our tendency to fantasy bond with someone or to become reliant on them once you have overshared or shared this big, honest thing about yourself. You suddenly feel like
某人建立亲密关系，这可能会导致我们向他们透露也许是我们经历的元素、我们旅程的元素，而这些是我们透露得太早了，导致我们过快地产生依恋。几乎是因为，正如我所说，我们觉得这个人需要做好准备。就像我们是这样一种东西，如果我们现在不告诉他们，他们会感到惊讶。他们会认为是我们诱骗他们坠入爱河的。这只是，我认为，一个真正的负面心理螺旋。就像我说的，这并不是说你不应该敞开心扉。但我认为我们需要意识到的一件事是，如果你是一个带着心理健康问题约会的人，也许我们倾向于对某人产生幻想依恋，或者一旦你过度分享或分享了关于你自己的这个诚实的大秘密，就会依赖他们。你突然觉得
they could be your savior, that they could make your mental health better. They can fix you. And I've had that experience and it's not anything to feel any shame around because that's really what we all want, right? Like we want someone to sit across from us for us to tell them and show them who we are and for them to say, I'll take all of it. I'll love you anyway. And we get to that point through sharing and through vulnerability and raw conversation. But I also think that we put love on a pedestal and when everything else in your life might
他们可能是你的救世主，他们可以改善你的心理健康。他们可以修复你。我也有过这种经历，这没什么好感到羞耻的，因为这确实是我们大家所渴望的，对吧？就像我们希望有人坐在我们对面，让我们告诉他们并向他们展示我们是谁，然后他们说：“我全盘接受。无论如何我都会爱你的。”我们通过分享、脆弱和原始的对话达到那个点。但我也认为，我们将爱情奉上了神坛，当生活中所有其他事情可能
not be working out when you kind of like got this black cloud over your head. sometimes we expect more from love and from the people who provide it than we should. We think that they're going to be the antidote to everything going on in our mind and we create false expectations. The biggest reason why I'm kind of raising this and why I think it's an important part of the conversation around dating and mental health, it's very easy to get carried away by the idea of someone fixing you and for that to result in you kind of giving up all your other coping skills and giving up the things that actually keep you healthy and then maybe having them
都不顺利，当你脑海中挥之不去一片乌云时。有时我们对爱以及提供爱的人的期望超过了我们应有的水平。我们认为他们将成为我们心中一切问题的解药，并产生了错误的期望。我提出这一点的主要原因以及我认为它是约会和心理健康对话中重要部分的原因是，很容易被某人修复你的想法冲昏头脑，这会导致你放弃所有其他应对技巧，放弃那些真正让你保持健康的习惯，然后可能让他们
leave, having them walk away and watching your mental health plummet like it never has before. When we become over-reliant on someone, before they prove to us that they are deserving of that trust and of that honesty and of that vulnerability, suddenly we are left without the coping skills that we really need. I think what's worse is when people almost fetishize, your mental health condition or your struggles. Like the fact that you are quote unquote like tortured. I see that word all the time and like books where a character has past trauma or has a mental health condition.
离开，看着他们走开，看着你的心理健康像从未有过的那样直线下降。当我们对某人过度依赖，在他们向我们证明他们配得上这种信任、诚实和脆弱之前，突然之间，我们发现自己失去了真正需要的应对技巧。我认为更糟糕的是，当人们几乎将你的心理健康状况或挣扎浪漫化或神圣化时。就像你所谓的“饱受折磨”一样。我在书里经常看到这个词，比如一个角色有过去的创伤或患有心理健康状况。
Like they're suddenly this like poetic thing when in fact they're not like a piece of art. They're not like your manic pixie dream girl. They're just a person. They're just a person. This is part of their story. And I think when we romanticize or let people romanticize or let people romanticize. romanticize our experiences, they begin to see us as that, rather than as someone who is so much more than perhaps a label that has been put on us. One, like, example of this that I'm really
他们突然变成了这种充满诗意的东西，事实上他们不是一件艺术品。他们不像你那异想天开的狂热梦幻女孩（manic pixie dream girl）。他们只是一个人。他们只是一个人。这是他们故事的一部分。并且我认为，当我们浪漫化或让别人浪漫化、让别人将我们的经历浪漫化时，他们开始把我们看作那样的人，而不是把我们看作一个远比被贴上的标签要多得多的人。对此的一个例子，我真的
specifically thinking about is the, like, attracting people who have a savior complex. So in psychology, the savior complex refers to a person, an individual, that has a strong tendency to seek out others who need help and who are looking for a savior. They're looking for someone to assist them, maybe because they are in a bad place. It doesn't make that person a bad person. It's not always malicious, but sometimes people date other people for self-serving reasons because it makes them feel good to be the helper, to be this great person. And when we examine that deeper, these people really benefit from you needing them. They have an ulterior motive to keep you stuck in a dark place. And it's not always conscious, but if your relationship has been founded on,
特别想到的是，吸引有“救世主情结”的人。所以在心理学中，“救世主情结”是指一个人，个体，有强烈的倾向去寻找那些需要帮助、寻找救世主的人。他们在寻找可以协助他们的人，也许是因为他们处境糟糕。这并不意味着那个人是个坏人。它并不总是恶意的，但有时人们出于自私的原因与其他人约会，因为当帮手、当这个伟大的人让他们感觉很好。当我们更深入地检查这一点时，这些人真的从你需要他们中受益。他们有着不可告人的动机，想让你陷入黑暗的深渊。这并不总是有意识的，但如果你们的关系建立在以下基础上：
firstly, that like intense bonding over experiences, but then also your, you know, that this, you needing this person, it's very hard to learn other ways to cope and to manage because it means that you might need them less. And they might therefore need you less as well because you no longer fit this like image of this like interesting tortured individual. It's why I think sometimes we see a lot of codependency in relationships between people who are struggling and people who are not. It's important to remember that although it's a hard truth, no one else is responsible for your mental health. That is all up to you, sadly, and it's very hard. But also, you are not your mental health condition.
首先，那种通过经历进行的强烈绑定，然后还有你的，你知道，你，你需要这个人，很难学习其他应对和管理的方法，因为这意味着你可能不那么需要他们了。因此他们可能也不那么需要你了，因为你不再符合这种“有趣而饱受折磨的个人”的形象。这就是为什么我认为有时我们在挣扎的人和不挣扎的人之间的关系中看到很多相互依赖。重要的是要记住，尽管这是一个残酷的真相，但没有人对你的心理健康负责。不幸的是，这全靠你自己，这非常困难。但是，你也不是你的心理健康状况。
You're more than that. You deserve someone who loves you, mental health and all not in spite of. of it. Definitely not. But also it doesn't need to be glamorized. There is a lot that we can romanticise in our lives. But I don't think that poor mental health is one of them. And we certainly don't want someone else to be doing it for us. So I think that is something to be aware of, not just for people with depression, but all conditions, how mental health can cause us to attach very quickly to people, to become reliant on them, to see them as a savior, to see love as something that will fix our problems. That also applies to conditions like anxiety as well, which is probably a great
你远不止于此。你值得拥有一个爱你的人，连同你的心理健康一起，而不是尽管有它。绝对不是。但它也不需要被美化。我们的生活中有很多可以浪漫化的事情。但我认为糟糕的心理健康不是其中之一。我们当然不希望别人为我们这样做。所以我认为这是需要注意的事情，不仅对抑郁症患者如此，对所有病症都是如此，心理健康如何会导致我们非常迅速地依恋人们，对他们产生依赖，将他们视为救世主，将爱视为解决我们问题的东西。这也适用于像焦虑症这样的状况，
segue into talking about it. Anxiety, I think, is more than just being stressed or worried from time to time. It can bring a constant sense of doom, of irritability, of restlessness, and so many are hypervigilance, the whole list. And I think the most common types of anxiety that we really see our generalized anxiety disorder, social anxiety, panic disorder. Let's focus on social anxiety just for a second here. I think the relationship and why social anxiety might make it harder today is maybe obvious, but still worth examining. Obviously, it brings a certain shyness and introversion because what you're anxious about is not general things, is not the future, although that might still be something you think about. It's how other people perceive you.
这可能是一个很好的过渡，可以开始谈论它。我认为，焦虑不仅仅是偶尔感到压力或担忧。它能带来一种持续的末日感、易怒感、坐立不安感，以及高度警惕，等等。我认为我们真正看到的最常见的焦虑类型是广泛性焦虑障碍、社交焦虑、恐慌障碍。让我们在这里重点关注社交焦虑一会。我认为社交焦虑使约会变得更困难的关系和原因可能很明显，但仍然值得探讨。显然，它带来了一定程度的害羞和内向，因为你焦虑的不是一般的事情，不是未来，尽管那可能仍然是你思考的事情。而是其他人如何看待你。
It's how other people, the acknowledgement, that other people have an opinion of you, that you might not be able to control and that their opinion matters. And that kind of acknowledgement, that experience can cause us to be quite closed off to the possibility of dating and meeting you people. And it might feel like whilst everyone else is having these experiences, you're kind of held back because you, that's not that you can't do it, but it's just harder for you to put yourself in those novel situations with people that you don't know. I hear a lot of people be like, oh, just go on dates, you know, just put yourself out there,
是其他人如何看待你，这种认知，即其他人对你有看法，而你可能无法控制，并且他们的这种看法很重要。这种认知、这种经历会导致我们对约会和结识新朋友的可能性相当封闭。这可能会让人觉得，当其他人都在经历这些时，你却有点被拖后腿了，因为你，并不是你做不到，而是你更难把自己置于那些与你不认识的人在一起的新奇境地中。我听到很多人说，哦，去约会吧，你知道，去展现自己，
not realizing how much more complicated and difficult that is when your brain is going a million miles an hour every waking moment. And you have this like intense perception of everything that could go wrong. You feel that people's opinions more deeply. You're more hypervigilant to perceive social threats. And I think one of the foundational parts of dating that that doesn't quite mesh well with is that part of dating is you want people to like you. But often we become too focused on that, such that we can't enjoy the moment, we can't enjoy the process. We think that we should be more like this person or make ourselves more like this version of us
却没有意识到当你的大脑在醒着的每一刻都以每小时数百万英里的速度运转时，这是多么复杂和困难。你对所有可能出错的事情有着强烈的感知。你对别人的看法感受得更深。你对感知到的社交威胁更加高度警惕。我认为约会的一个基本部分与这一点并不完全契合，那就是约会的一部分是你希望别人喜欢你。但通常我们过于关注这一点，以至于我们无法享受当下，无法享受这个过程。我们认为我们应该更像这个人，或者把自己塑造成这个版本的我们
in order to get this person's approval and to avoid the social rejection that we fear. How this shows up is something that I like to call an anxiety spiral, particularly before things, like first dates or even like second, third dates, you know, should I wear this? What will they think if I wear that? What will they think about if I answer this question this way? What will they think if I double text them? Like so many different fears that we have around what this person is thinking. It can cause us to feel really overwhelmed to say things we don't mean to cancel dates last minute to leave early, especially like for those of us with a panic disorder. It's a fear around what will happen if I have a panic attack during the date? How embarrassing. And it's that fear spiral. It's
为了获得这个人的认可并避免我们害怕的社交拒绝。这表现出来的方式是我喜欢称之为“焦虑螺旋”的东西，特别是在一些事情发生之前，比如第一次约会，甚至第二次、第三次约会，你知道，“我应该穿这个吗？如果我穿那个，他们会怎么想？如果我这样回答这个问题，他们会怎么想？如果我发双条信息，他们会怎么想？”我们对这个人在想什么有着如此之多的不同恐惧。这会让我们感到不知所措，说出并非本意的话，最后一分钟取消约会，提前离开，尤其是对于我们这些患有恐慌障碍的人来说。这是一种对“如果在约会期间我恐慌发作会发生什么？”的恐惧。多尴尬啊。正是这种恐惧螺旋。是
that catastrophizing, that future telling, that predicting, that can lead to avoidance. The easiest way to not feel fear is to not put yourself in those situations, right? So whilst one person might not think twice about walking into a blind date with someone they don't know, for someone else, it takes a lot more mental preparation. And sometimes it's easier to just not have those experiences because they are so stressful and so overwhelming. And it's not that you don't want love. It's not that you are like not putting yourself out there. It's not that you don't want to put yourself out there.
这种灾难化思维、这种未卜先知、这种预测，会导致回避。不感受恐惧的最简单方法就是不让自己陷入那些情况，对吧？因此，当一个人对和一个不认识的人进行盲目约会可能不会多想时，对另一个人来说，这需要更多的心理准备。有时，干脆不经历那些事情会更容易，因为它们压力太大了，太让人不知所措了。这并不是说你不想要爱。这并不是说你就像没有展现自己一样。这并不是说你不想展现自己。
It's so much more complicated. And I think sometimes that's something that people just can't say. I also want to talk about the impact of swipe based dating apps like hinge, Tinder, Bumble, and how they've been shown to impact our mental health in this centuries. Not even in this century. in the last like five to 10 years. So there is one pretty amazing paper on this. It's actually one of the only pieces of research actually on this topic.
事情要复杂得多。我认为有时那是人们根本无法说出口的。我还想谈谈基于滑动交友的约会软件（如Hinge、Tinder、Bumble）的影响，以及它们在最近几个世纪中如何被证明会影响我们的心理健康。甚至不是在这个世纪。在过去的五到十年里。有一篇关于这个的非常棒的论文。它实际上是关于这个主题的仅有的研究之一。
And it was published in 2020. And it really takes a deep dive into how dating apps have changed not just how we date, but the subsequent mental health impacts that come with constantly being able to scroll thousands of profiles and have your attractiveness and perceive desirability, validated or dismissed by strangers at all hours of the day. Yes, I think dating apps have expanded our options. If we're talking about anxiety, you know, it's really great for people with social anxiety at times. It means that they have more time to talk to someone online. You know, it's more accessible. But it's also a lot more stress-inducing. This study, the one I was just speaking about,
它发表于2020年，深入探讨了约会软件如何不仅改变了我们的约会方式，还带来了随之而来的心理健康影响，即不断能够滚动浏览数千个个人资料，并在一天中的任何时间让陌生人验证或驳回你的吸引力和感知到的意愿。是的，我认为约会软件扩大了我们的选择。如果我们谈论焦虑，你知道，有时它对有社交焦虑的人真的很好。这意味着他们有更多时间在网上与人交谈。你知道，它更易于接触。但它也更容易引起压力。这项研究，也就是我刚才谈到的那个，
it showed that people who are using dating apps do report higher levels of depression, high levels of anxiety, higher levels of comparison, of distress compared to those who don't use these applications. And that's probably for a few reasons. Firstly, if you're not having the success that you want, that can be incredibly demoralizing, incredibly painful. But additionally, when your emotional resources and ability to cope is already being taxed by mental health concerns, it means that you're a lot more sensitive to these perceived rejections. And that is the second component of why I think dating apps in particular are hard for people who have anxiety or any type of mental health condition because of what we call rejection sensitivity.
表明使用约会软件的人确实报告了更高水平的抑郁、高水平的焦虑、更高水平的比较，与不使用这些应用程序的人相比有更高的痛苦感。这可能是出于几个原因。首先，如果你没有取得想要的成功，那可能会非常令人沮丧，非常痛苦。此外，当你的情感资源和应对能力已经被心理健康问题消耗时，这意味着你对这些感知到的拒绝更加敏感。这是我认为约会软件对有焦虑症或任何类型心理健康状况的人来说特别艰难的第二个原因，因为我们所说的“拒绝敏感性”。
Dating involves a lot more nose than it does. some people, especially those with anxiety or ADHD or BPD, experience a more severe reaction and emotional pain to being rejected than others. So they looked into this back in 2021 and they confirmed that link. And what they coined was this term called dating anxiety. And what that really comes to tell us is that there are certain people who, their anxiety is so specific that it becomes, it comes to revolver this very experience of dating, of having to meet people, new people, who could potentially,
约会涉及的“不”比“是”要多得多。有些人，尤其是那些有焦虑症、多动症或边缘型人格障碍的人，对被拒绝会产生更严重的反应和情感痛苦。因此，他们在2021年对此进行了调查，并证实了这种联系。他们创造的这个词叫做“约会焦虑”。这实际上告诉我们的是，某些人，他们的焦虑是如此具体，以至于它变成了，围绕着约会这种经历，不得不结识新的人，他们可能会潜在地，
you know, be the love of your life, but also is more likely than not going to not be a great experience, you know, as hard as that is. Like I said, like, dating is basically like a constant rejection exercise for a lot of people. And if your rejection sensitivity is heightened, it's going to mean that every time these things happen, every time you're ghosted, every time someone doesn't match with you, every time someone doesn't reply to you, it's going to mean that those things, you feel them a lot more deeply. It makes it harder to bounce back. And it makes you look for other conclusions to that person's perceived rejection. It makes you look into what is wrong with you. Anxious people are not only, I think, the biggest overthinkers out there, but also some of the
你知道，成为你一生中的挚爱，但也更有可能不是一次美好的经历，尽管这很难。就像我说的，就像，对于很多人来说，约会基本上是一个持续的拒绝练习。如果你的拒绝敏感性提高了，这意味着每当这些事情发生时，每当被无视（ghosted）时，每当有人不和你匹配时，每当有人不回复你时，这意味着这些事情，你感受得更深刻。这让你更难振作起来。并且它让你寻找对那个人感知到的拒绝的其他结论。它让你寻找自己身上有什么问题。焦虑的人不仅是，我认为，外面最大的过度思考者，而且也是世界上最聪明的一些人，因为他们的大脑在不断寻找每个问题的答案，甚至是尚未发生的问题，甚至与他们无关、他们永远找不到答案的问题。有人在约会软件上没有给你回信。有数百万种不同的结论。有人没有邀请你进行第二次约会，关于原因也有数百万个不同的答案。但我们在没有找出原因之前是无法前进的，通常当我们没有来自对方的答案时，我们会向内看。我们对自己的回应变得很有创造力，并且我们将以下观点内化：如果这个人不够喜欢我们，无法将其提升到下一个水平，无法继续。
most intelligent people in the world because their brains are constantly looking for answers to every problem, even problems that haven't happened yet, even problems that have nothing to do with them that they will never find an answer for. Someone hasn't messaged you back on a dating app. There are a million different conclusions. Someone hasn't asked you on a second date, there are also a million different answers as to why. But we cannot move forward without finding out why and normally when we don't have the answers from the other person, we look internally. We become very creative about our responses and we internalize that there must be something wrong with us if this person didn't like us enough to take it to the next level, to keep
见我们，无法给我们回信，那么我们身上一定有什么问题。这会降低我们的自信心，降低我们的自尊。它真的会导致焦虑螺旋，但也会加剧诸如我们的被抛弃问题或焦虑或回避型依恋风格之类的事情，如果你是一个焦虑的人，你对可能触发你的事情的阈值自然要低得多，这意味着它更敏感，这意味着其他人可能会忽略的事情，其他人可能会认为只是游戏一部分的事情，会对你产生更多影响，并且也会导致我们质疑我们的价值、我们的判断力。以及我们所能提供的东西。
seeing us to message us back. And that reduces our self-confidence, reduces our self-esteem. It can really lead to an anxiety spiral, but also exacerbate things like our abandonment issues or an anxious or avoidant attachment style, your threshold for what might be triggering you is naturally, if you are someone with anxiety, a lot lower, meaning that it's more sensitive, meaning that things that other people might ignore, things that other people might dismiss, might see as just kind of like part of the game, impact you a lot more, and also cause us to question our value, our value, our judgment. and kind of what we have to offer.
这就是为什么如果你是一个正在与心理健康作斗争同时又在约会的人，你将不得不设立比没有这些经历的人更强的界限。有几个原因。糟糕的约会经历、忽视潜在的危险信号（红旗）、糟糕的人，它们会以非常、非常严重的方式恶化我们的心理健康。有医学证据支持，糟糕的约会、糟糕的恋爱关系、糟糕的“情境关系”（situationships）会导致压力，它们会损害你的免疫系统，主要是因为这些情况会增加我们的皮质醇，它们让我们处于一种压力状态，如果这种状态没有得到解决，就会给我们的身体施加如此多的额外压力，
That is why if you are someone who struggles with their mental health and is also dating, you are going to have to set stronger boundaries than people who don't have those experiences. And there's a few reasons why. Bad dating experiences, overlooking potential red flags, bad people, they can worsen our mental health in very, very severe and serious ways. there is medical evidence to support that bad dates bad relationships bad situationships they can cause stress they can damage your immune system mainly because those situations increase our cortisol they put us in a stress state that if it isn't resolved put so much additional pressure on our body
以至于它占用了我们所有的资源，我们需要在生活其他方面进行应对的所有资源。我们的精神能量是一种有限的资源，所以当一种经历、生活的一个方面需要我们付出很多时，比如一连串糟糕的约会，或者一堆被已读不回的信息，或者一个不回复你或对你不好的人，或者一个总是拖着你、吊着你的人。这些在精神上非常繁重，以至于它们夺走了我们需要投入到其他事情中的资源。它们也可以表现为一个诱发因素。即使是健康的爱也可以是一个诱发因素，因为正如我之前所说，爱让我们变得极其脆弱。它只是要求你更加开放，对连接更加开放，是的，但也对痛苦、心碎、受到伤害更加开放。
that it takes up all of our resources all of the resources that we need to cope in other areas of our life our mental energy is a finite resource so when one experience when one aspect of our life is requiring a lot from us, like a string of bad dates, or a bunch of messages left on red, or a person who doesn't reply or who treats you badly, or who just like keeps, you know, she keeps dragging you along, leading you on. Those are so mentally taxing that they take resources that we need to devote to other things. They can also present as a trigger. Even healthy love can be a trigger, because, as I said before, love leaves us incredibly vulnerable. It just demands that you be more open, more open to connection, yes, but also more open to pain, to heartbreak, to being hurt.
这是精神上要求很高的。它在情感上是相当危险的。当事情出错时，你的心理健康将受到影响。这并不是为了吓唬你。这只是为了让你确保自己意识到你需要更加意识到你应该为自己要求什么，你正在让谁进入你的生活。而且，你知道，我有一个关于这个的故事，关于我约会过的一个人。就像我的第一个男朋友，我做了所有不该做的事。我在这里要承担责任。
It is mentally demanding. It's emotionally quite perilous. And when things go wrong, your mental health will be impacted. And that's not to scare you. It's just to like make sure that you're aware that you need to be more conscious of what you should be demanding for yourself, who you are letting in. And, you know, I have a story about this about someone I dated. It was like my first boyfriend and I did everything that you weren't meant to do. I'm going to take accountability here.
就像，我和这个人进行了创伤绑定。我在依赖他的同时，却忽视了他有救世主情结的所有迹象。我抛弃了经过实践检验的自我护理习惯以及日常生活中让我保持快乐、稳定和良好状态的重要部分。然后他和我分手了。这把我推到了一个如此低的低谷。它完全扰乱了我所认为的正常状态。它造成了情绪失衡，并导致了一场长达大约三个月的相当大规模的抑郁发作。
Like, I trauma bonded with this person. I became reliant on him whilst also ignoring all the signs that he had a savior complex. I abandoned my tried and tested self-care habits and the important parts of my routine that were keeping me happy and stable and in a good place. And then he broke up with me. And that pushed me to such a low point. it completely disrupted what I felt was normal. It created emotional imbalance and it resulted in like a pretty massive depressive episode that was like three months long.
就好像，我和这个人建立了一种创伤纽带。我开始依赖他，同时却忽视了他有救世主情结的所有信号。我放弃了那些经受过考验、屡试不爽的自我关怀习惯，以及那些能让我保持快乐、稳定和良好状态的日常生活中的重要部分。然后他和我分手了。这把我推到了一个如此低谷的境地，彻底打乱了我所认为的正常生活。它造成了情绪失衡，并导致了一场长达大约三个月的相当严重的抑郁发作。
And I think obviously that's a very serious case, but it happens a lot with things that are less serious. Like you just have to realize that your sensitivity and your threshold might be lower than other people because you do have such a big heart because you do have so many other things going on that small things that other people can dismiss might hurt you in. injure your sense of worth, your self-esteem more than others. And I want you to ask yourself, you know, is a short attachment or a fling or a burst of romance with someone who might not be treating you well who might not want what you want? Is it worth jeopardizing your mental health?
我认为这显然是一个非常严重的案例，但这种情况在不那么严重的事情中也经常发生。比如，你只需要意识到，你的敏感度和心理阈值可能会比其他人低，因为你确实有一颗博大的心，因为你身上还有很多其他事情在发生，所以其他人可以不放在心上的小事，可能会伤害到你。会比其他人更多地损害你的价值感和自尊心。我想问问你，你知道的，一段短暂的感情、一次短暂的露水情缘，或者与一个可能对你不好、可能不想要你想要的东西的人之间的一阵浪漫，值得吗？这值得你拿心理健康去冒险吗？
That is one of the most important resources that you have. You cannot, I guess I get it back, like it's so hard to rebuild. It is precious and it is delicate. So when you are dating people, really ask yourself, is this person proving to me that they are safe? Is it going to cost me my mental health to be with them? I think the answer to that question isn't always clear, but I want to provide some tips on how to, I don't want to say keep yourself safe because that is slightly dramatic, but more so how to date with your mental health and emotional well-being as a priority. And also some advice for people who are dating partners who struggle with their mental health. How can you show up as a really good person in this person's life. How can you help them without being overbearing,
那是你拥有的最重要的资源之一。你不可能，我想我能找回来，就像重建它是多么困难一样。它是珍贵而脆弱的。因此，当你在和别人约会时，真的要问问自己，这个人是否在向我证明他是安全的？和他们在一起会损害我的心理健康吗？我认为这个问题的答案并不总是那么明确，但我想提供一些关于如何……我不想说保护自己，因为那有点戏剧化，而是更多地关于如何把心理健康和情绪健康放在首位来约会。还有一些给那些正在与心理健康做斗争的伴侣约会的人的建议。你怎么能成为这个人生命中一个真正的好人呢？你如何在不过度干涉的情况下帮助他们？
without becoming that kind of savior character that we were speaking about? So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with researchers and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will
没有变成我们刚才说的救世主那样的人？好了，这段短暂的休息之后，将会有更多精彩内容。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。我将与研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你就会
come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to two percent. That's T-W-O-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield.
以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听《百分之二》。也就是iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWOP-Sent”。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔d。
And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
在新一季的《女友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，才不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So
我愿意在白天谈论可卡因，但为了让你们知道，我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看到了一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以
Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah For me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了，真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾过去》在iHeartRadio应用，Apple Podcasts
Or wherever you get your podcast Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你能真正做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. We face a lot of misconceptions when we date as people, myself included, who have had ups and downs with our mental health. And one of the biggest misconceptions I hear is that because you are depressed, because you are anxious, because you need more reassurance, because you catastrophes, because you need more rest, whatever it is, that you are somehow less deserving of love, that it is harder in some way for people to love you.
加入我，卡尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难成长》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。我们在约会时面临着很多误解，包括我自己，我们对心理健康都有过起伏。我听到的最大误解之一是，因为你抑郁了，因为你焦虑了，因为你需要更多的保证，因为你灾难化，因为你需要更多的休息，无论是什么，你不知何故更不值得被爱，在某种程度上，别人很难去爱你。
There is not a tiny, tiny part of that that is true, not at all. And I think when we, I don't want to say let ourselves believe it, but when we take that as a truth, when we hear that too often, we settle for less because we begin to think, well, if I'm hard to love, I should take what I'm given. And I should be happy with it because it's better than nothing. And that is the absolute worst mindset that we can have when it comes to like looking for love. you are deserving of just so much, so much, if not more.
这其中没有哪怕一分一毫是真的，一点也没有。我认为当我们，我不想说让自己相信这一点，但当我们把这当作真理，当我们听到这句话太频繁时，我们会妥协，因为我们开始想，好吧，如果我很难被爱，我就该接受我所得到的一切。我应该为此感到高兴，因为这总比没有强。而这绝对是我们寻找真爱时能有的最糟糕的心态。你值得拥有如此之多，哪怕不是更多。
You are so incredibly open-hearted and sensitive and empathetic. You see the world differently. Like, that is amazing. And I think we need to ensure that we are open to the love that we deserve whilst also really taking care of ourselves. So here are some of my tips. Number one, don't feel like you need to give people a reason if you're a little off, especially in the early stages of dating.
你的心胸如此宽广，敏感而有同理心。你看待世界的方式与众不同。这太棒了。我认为我们需要确保我们对我们应得的爱保持开放，同时也真正照顾好自己。所以这里是我的一些建议。第一，如果你状态有点不对劲，不要觉得自己需要给别人一个理由，尤其是在约会的早期阶段。
you don't need to be explicit or over-explain yourself. If you need to cancel a date because you're having an episode or because you're just really anxious, just say, you know, you don't have to give them the exact reason. Sometimes I think honesty is not the best policy. And we're not doing this from a place of like, what if I scare them off? Like, absolutely not. It's more that we want to protect ourselves from feeling closer to this person than we need to before they've proved to us that they deserve to feel close to us. Hopefully that makes sense.
你不需要说得太露骨或过度解释自己。如果你需要取消约会，因为你正在发作，或者因为你真的很焦虑，就直说吧，你知道的，你不需要给出确切的原因。有时我认为诚实并不是最好的策略。我们这样做不是出于“万一我把他们吓跑了怎么办”的想法？绝对不是。更多的是因为我们想保护自己，在他们向我们证明自己值得我们感觉亲近之前，不要让自己对这个人的感觉比我们需要的感觉更近。希望这说得通。
But I think if we like immediately are like, sorry, I need to cancel the date, like, I'm super depressed because, you know, my pet just died and, oh, I've had, you know, ongoing depression for three years and blah, like, obviously, like, eventually, if this person, like, works out, you can tell them all those things. You should tell them all those things. But in the early stages, I do think, as we spoke about in the first half of this episode, you don't want to become. like feel like you're relying on this person or feel like because you've shared something with them that suddenly the relationship is more important than it actually is. So don't feel like you need, that they need to know everything about you up front. I think that prevents trauma bonding and it
但我认为，如果我们立刻说，抱歉，我需要取消约会，因为，你知道的，我超级沮丧，因为我的宠物刚刚死 了，噢，你知道的，我有持续三年的抑郁症等等，显然，最终，如果这个人，你知道的，合适的话，你可以告诉他们所有这些事情。你应该把所有这些事情都告诉他们。但在早期阶段，我确实认为，正如我们在本集前半部分所讨论的那样，你不想变得……就像觉得你依赖这个人一样，或者觉得因为你和他们分享了某些东西，突然间这段关系变得比实际情况更重要。所以不要觉得你需要，他们需要一开始就知道关于你的一切。我认为这可以防止创伤纽带，它
allows you to kind of create some some distance, some healthy distance so that you continue to ensure that you are coping without looking to them to be your savior, looking to them to be your distraction. some ways that we can do that. Obviously, like, you don't need to be explicit if things are happening, especially not if it's like before a first date or like even I would say in the first three dates. And also create space between your dates as well so that you don't feel like, I think this doesn't even just relate to people with mental health concerns, but everyone, like sometimes when you spend like three days in a row with someone, like you're automatically going to see them as like a more important part of your life than someone that you went on three dates with.
能让你创造一些距离，一些健康的距离，这样你就能继续确保自己能够应对，而不是指望他们成为你的救世主，指望他们成为你的分心源。我们可以做到这一点的一些方法。很明显，比如，如果事情发生了，你不需要说得太明白，特别是如果在第一次约会之前，或者甚至我可以说在前三次约会中。而且还要在你的约会之间留出空间，这样你才不会觉得，我认为这不仅适用于有心理健康问题的人，每个人都这样，有时当你连续三天和某人在一起时，你会自动把他们看作是你生活中更重要的一部分，而不是你与之约会了三次的人。
like over the span of three weeks. So try and like give yourself time, give yourself space to actually get to know someone. Try not to date as a distraction from your mental health, from taking care of yourself or at the expense of your mental health. If you know that you are going through a really hard time and that maybe one of your tendencies is to self-sabotage, is to self-destruct. And the way you do that is through dating. You know that about yourself. You know that. So try not to use other people to use like the allure of love as a solution, as a distraction, as kind of like a tool that isn't dependable. Do you know what I mean? Like mental health is so delicate. But also I think after a period of time, you kind of understand what works for you is that taking your medication on time,
比如在三周的时间里。所以试着给自己时间，给自己空间去真正了解某人。尽量不要为了转移注意力而约会，不要为了逃避照顾自己而约会，也不要以牺牲你的心理健康为代价来约会。如果你知道你正在经历一段非常艰难的时期，也许你的倾向之一是自我毁灭，是自我破坏。而你做到这一点的方式就是通过约会。你对自己很了解。你知道的。所以尽量不要利用别人，利用爱的诱惑作为解决方案，作为一种分心的方式，作为一种不可靠的工具。你知道我的意思吗？就像心理健康是如此脆弱。但我也认为，经过一段时间后，你会明白什么对你有效，是按时服药，
is that making sure that you have a loan time and time to reset? Is it making sure that you're doing enough exercise that you're going to therapy? And if there is a relationship that is getting in the way of you doing those things, those things that you know are independently really good for you, because you are using this person as a distraction, because they seem to be offering you this like huge, big, glowing, life-changing antidote that is love. Take a step back.
是确保你有独处的时间和重置的时间吗？是确保你做了足够的运动，你去接受治疗吗？如果有这样一段关系阻碍了你做这些事情，那些你知道对你独立来说真的很好的事情，因为你把这个人当成了一种分心，因为他们似乎向你提供了一种巨大、发光、改变人生的解药，那就是爱。退后一步。
also don't be afraid to say that doesn't work for me like if you have things that you need to do to protect your mental health you don't owe this person anything right like the most important person in your life is you and taking care of you should always be priority don't worry about upsetting them don't worry about letting them down that is a people pleasing habit that is obviously more common amongst people who are anxious or amongst people who have some kind of trauma to do with dating, you're allowed to say, no, that doesn't work for me. You're allowed to say, you're allowed to, like, put up boundaries and you're allowed to, like, continue to prioritize yourself, even if this other person, like, might be bothered by it, even if they might be upset, even if it doesn't work for them.
也不要害怕说这对我不适用，如果你有需要做的事情来保护你的心理健康，你不欠这个人任何东西，对吧？你生命中最重要的人是你自己，照顾好自己应该永远是首要任务。不要担心惹他们生气，不要担心让他们失望，这是一种取悦他人的习惯，这在焦虑的人或在约会有某种创伤的人中显然更常见，你可以说，不，这对我不管用。你可以说，你可以设立界限，你可以继续把优先权留给自己，即使这个人可能会为此烦恼，即使他们可能会不安，即使这对他们不管用。
If you are also an anxious person when dating, get off the apps or limit your notifications. I did this a lot because I would get like these phantom buzzers. I'm such an anxious data, right? Because I am an anxious person that immediately after I'd matched with something, everything matched with someone, like everything would just feel more heightened. There was so much expectation because I was always overthinking everything and I was always like looking to predict the future. And so I found that like I would always be checking my phone.
如果你在约会时也是一个焦虑的人，请卸载软件或限制你的通知。我经常这样做，因为我会得到这种幻觉般的振动。我是一个如此焦虑的约会者，对吧？因为我是一个焦虑的人，在我跟某人配对之后，一切都会立刻感觉更加高涨。有太多的期望，因为我总是想太多，我总是试图预测未来。所以我发现我总是忍不住看手机。
I was always like overly worried about when this person was going to get back to me. Like what they'd said if they'd match with me. turn off your notifications and only check them twice a day. Once a day. I don't know. Set like a time period that feels reasonable for you and stick to it so that you don't feel like this thing, this app, this like weird holy grail of like potential dates, has control over your emotional reactions and has control over your mood. If whether or not someone matched with you that day or whether or not this man replied
我总是过分担心这个人什么时候会回复我。比如他们说了什么，如果他们跟我配对的话。关闭你的通知，一天只看两次。一天一次。我不知道。设定一个对你来说合理的时限并坚持下去，这样你就不会觉得这个东西，这个App，这个潜在约会对象的诡异圣杯，控制了你的情绪反应，控制了你的情绪。不管那天是否有人跟你配对，或者这个男人是否回复了
to you or this woman or this person replied to you, is impacting your mood. That is a really good point time to be like, I'm going to set a boundary here. This is not healthy. This is not serving me. This is not good for my health. And my health is, I'm most about to be like, health is wealth. Very cheesy, very Dr. Seuss vibes.
你，或者这个女人，这个人是否回复了你，正在影响你的心情。这真的是一个很好的时机去说，我要在这里划清界限。这不健康。这对我没有帮助。这对我的健康不利。而我的健康是，我最想说的是健康就是财富。非常俗气，非常有苏斯博士的风格。
But it really is. It really is. And I think it's worth it to take a step back, even if you get less of the validation, even if you feel like you're less actively dating and pursuing love in order to really like rest and sit in what you need. If you are dating after trauma or a heart experience, I also say, like, go on dates that are low pressure. Go on dates at a low effort so you don't get too invested at the start.
但确实如此。确实如此。我认为退后一步是值得的，即使你得到的认可减少了，即使你觉得你在积极约会和追求爱方面的投入减少了，为了真正休息并安于你所需要的东西。如果你在经历创伤或心碎后约会，我也建议，去进行压力不大的约会。去进行低精力的约会，这样你在开始时就不会投入过多。
Ask more questions of them than them of you to really test their emotional intelligence. I, like, have a few questions here that I asked, that I did ask, that really, like, allowed me to see whether this person is going to be accepting of me and everything that that brought. one of the best ones is to ask them the last time they cried. I know it sounds like so silly, but how someone responds to that question honestly actually tells you a lot about how they'll be not just in a relationship, but kind of how they see emotional reactions in general, how they treat their own emotions. And then maybe I should have said this tip earlier,
多问他们问题，而不是让他们问你，以真正测试他们的情商。我，我这里有一些我问过的问题，我确实问过，这真的让我能够看出这个人是否会接受我以及随之而来的一切。其中最好的一个是问他们上次哭是什么时候。我知道这听起来很傻，但一个人如何诚实地回答这个问题，实际上能告诉你很多关于他们将如何在关系中相处的信息，以及他们如何总体上看待情绪反应，他们如何对待自己的情绪。然后也许我应该早点说出这个建议，
but I think it kind of was obvious. Like sometimes you just need to stop dating. like if sometimes it's just not worth it it's just there are a lot of reasons why it's harder sometimes obviously the rejection sensitivity the self-worth the need to self-isolate the like the depressive episodes like sometimes it's just it's too hard and it's okay to just be like yeah i'm not dating at the moment it might seem like everyone else is doing it you don't need to be everyone you don't need to be everyone you don't need to be like putting yourself through an emotional roller coaster with the promise that maybe you'll meet someone because maybe you will meet someone, but maybe they'll hurt
但我觉得这有点明显。有时你只需要停止约会。就像有时这根本不值得，有很多原因导致它有时更困难，显然是拒绝敏感、自我价值感、自我孤立的需求、抑郁发作，有时只是太难了，没关系，只要说，是的，我目前没有约会。这可能看起来像是其他所有人都在这样做，你不需要成为所有人，你不需要成为所有人，你不需要经历情感过山车，并承诺也许你会遇到某人，因为也许你会遇到某人，但也许他们会伤害
you more than you're prepared to be hurt at the moment, more than you are able to be hurt at the moment, you know, more than you can take. I think that's an important thing to think about. All right. So those are some of my tips. Take them or leave them, please. If you have others, tell me, I'll share them over on my Instagram. But I want to also just quickly talk about a quick, like, rapid fire list for people who might be listening to this episode seeking information about someone there dating who is struggling with depression, who is struggling with anxiety, who is struggling with a mental health condition. Coming from someone who I'm dating someone who is amazing at this, who is just, like, I don't know
你比你准备好受到的伤害更深，比你目前能够承受的伤害更深，你知道的，比你能承受的要多。我认为这是需要思考的重要事情。好了。这些就是我的一些建议。接受也罢，拒绝也罢，请随意。如果你有其他建议，告诉我，我会在我的Instagram上分享。但我也想简单谈谈一连串快速问答，针对那些可能正在收听这一集、寻找关于他们正在约会的人的信息的人，他们正在与抑郁症做斗争，正在与焦虑症做斗争，正在与心理健康状况做斗争。来自一个正在和一个在这方面做得非常棒的人约会的人，他只是，就像，我不知道
where he got this unique ability, this unique ability for just like empathy and just to know what to do. And I think I've learned a lot from him in terms of like what it means to show, up for someone in a relationship when they're struggling through what he's done and through how he's shown up for me. So firstly, let them talk or let them be silent. Don't be too pushy for answers because you think that them talking about something is going to make it better for them. I think sometimes we think that if we vocalize, like someone just needs to vocalize how they're feeling and they'll feel better. Like internalizing any problem means that we're suppressing it. we're not dealing with it. That is not how everyone's minds work. Sometimes we do need to be silent
他从哪里获得了这种独特的能力，这种对同理心和知道该做什么的独特能力。我想我从他身上学到了很多东西，关于在对方挣扎时，通过他所做的一切以及他如何支持我，在关系中支持一个人意味着什么。首先，让他们说话或让他们保持沉默。不要为了寻求答案而逼得太紧，因为你认为他们谈论某事会让他们感觉更好。我认为有时我们认为，如果我们将……就像某人只需要把他们的感受表达出来，他们就会感觉更好。将任何问题内化意味着我们在压抑它。我们没有在处理它。并不是所有人的大脑都是这样运作的。有时我们确实需要保持沉默
in order to process. Sometimes that is the best way for us to work through heavy emotions. So honestly, see yourself as like, almost like a priest, almost like someone who's willing to listen, someone who's willing to give advice based on what that person needs. Secondly, don't make them feel guilty for things not in their control. They cannot, like if you've had any experience with mental health. You'll know that you can try so hard to be something for someone else, can try so hard to show up for plans that you just mentally cannot, cannot do, you can try so hard to get out of bed, you can try so hard to suppress that need for reassurance, and it's not going to work. So as their partner, don't make them feel bad when they're probably already
为了进行处理。有时这是我们处理沉重情感的最佳方式。所以老实说，把你想象成，几乎就像一个牧师，几乎就像一个愿意倾听的人，一个愿意根据那个人的需求给出建议的人。其次，不要让他们为他们无法控制的事情感到内疚。他们不能，如果你有过任何心理健康方面的经验。你会知道，你可以非常努力地为别人成为某种人，你可以非常努力地出席你精神上根本无法做到的计划，你无法做到，你可以非常努力地起床，你可以非常努力地压抑对保证的需求，但这不会起作用。所以作为他们的伴侣，当他们可能已经
feeling bad enough for the ways that maybe their mental health is showing. up in your relationship in less than great ways. Thirdly, this probably should have been number one. Educate yourself. And you can educate yourself through speaking to them as well, because you can educate yourself on their exact symptoms, on their exact patterns of thinking, on how it shows up for them. But it's very easy to use Google. You can just have a little browse on what it is that this condition really means for someone, how it shows up in their life, what someone might need, so that you can also be able to have open conversations with this person, with this person you love. Be patient. Be patient. They're trying really hard. And I know you're probably trying really hard too.
因为他们的心理健康在你们的关系中以不太好的方式表现出来而感到足够糟糕时，不要让他们感觉更糟糕。第三，这本应该是第一条。教育你自己。你可以通过与他们交谈来教育自己，因为你可以了解他们的确切症状、他们的确切思维模式、它是如何为他们表现出来的。但使用谷歌非常简单。你可以随便浏览一下这种状况对某人意味着什么，它如何出现在他们的生活中，某人可能需要什么，这样你也能与这个人、你爱的人进行公开的对话。要有耐心。要有耐心。他们真的很努力。我知道你可能也很努力。
Both of you are trying really hard. Like that's a winning factor in a relationship. But be patient with them if they don't have all the answers for why they're feeling a certain way, right now. They might not have the answers. Mental health is a bit of a black box sometimes. Just let them take some time to process things themselves to talk to you when they need to talk to you and offer small creature comforts. Offer like a home cooked meal. Offer for you to offer to go out and get them the groceries that they need to just quickly vacuum their room. Things that like might be really mentally draining for them that you have the capacity to do. speaking of capacity though take care of yourself and know that it is okay to walk away you are not
你们两个都很努力。就像那是关系中的取胜因素。但如果他们对为什么会有某种感觉没有所有的答案，对他们要有耐心。他们可能没有答案。心理健康有时有点像黑匣子。只要让他们花点时间自己处理事情，需要在你面前谈论时跟你谈谈，并提供一些小小的物质安慰。提供一顿家常饭菜。提供出去帮他们买他们需要的杂货，或者快速给他们的房间吸尘。那些对他们来说可能在精神上非常消耗，而你有能力去做的事情。不过说到精力，照顾好你自己，要知道离开是没问题的，你不是
their carer but also don't blindside them and definitely don't give them ultimatums like you need to get better or or like i'll start coming over more once you start going to therapy every day or once you start taking a medication like that that is not it might feel like you're loving someone through tough love but I think it just causes a relationship to rip. It causes them to feel like they can't be honest with you. When you love someone, it's very easy to really want to show up for them. And almost like, it's like that saying, like you can take a horse to water, but you can't always make them drink.
他们的照顾者，但也不要突袭他们，绝对不要给他们下最后通牒，比如你需要好起来，或者如果……一旦你开始每天去治疗，或者一旦你开始吃药，我就会更多地过来，那可不行。这可能会让你觉得你是在用严厉的爱来爱一个人，但我认为这只会导致关系破裂。这会让他们觉得无法对你诚实。当你爱一个人的时候，很容易真的很想为他们付出。几乎就像，就像那句俗话，你可以把马牵到河边，但你不能强迫它喝水。
You might feel like you're helping by, because you know what's best for them, because you're this outside person. And sometimes you don't. You can gently encourage, but I think they know themselves quite well. at this point and they know what they need. And you don't need to be their carer. I think when a relationship takes on that kind of role takes on that dynamic, that's when things begin to fall apart.
你可能会觉得自己是在帮忙，因为你知道什么对他们最好，因为你是这个局外人。但有时你并不懂。你可以温柔地鼓励，但我认为他们非常了解自己，在这个时候，他们知道自己需要什么。你不需要成为他们的照顾者。我认为当一段关系承担起那种角色，承担起那种动态时，事情就开始瓦解了。
That's when we see codependency. That's when we see a heavy emotional reliance. That's when we see trauma bonding. And that's not really, I think, the marker of a good long-term relationship. You need to be your own people together. So I hope that this episode has been helpful. I understand that it might be rambly. Even as I was recording, I was like, there was so much to be said here, so much to pack
这就是我们看到共依赖的时候。这就是我们看到沉重的情感依赖的时候。这就是我们看到创伤纽带的时候。我认为这并不是一段好的长期关系的标志。你们需要一起成为独立的个体。所以希望这一集对大家有所帮助。我理解它可能会有些语无伦次。即使在录音时我也在想，这里有太多话要说，有太多内容要塞进
into like just this one episode. Honestly, there's so much more research that needs to be done on this. And there's so many more conversations that need to be done on this as well. Like we always think of mental health as like just deriving entirely from our choices in a way or it's biological, but there is so much about our environment, including like the people we're dating, the people were romantically involved with, that whole social process, that whole everything to do with it that does like have a very deep emotional and psychological impact. So I hope that you have learned something.
仅仅这一集里。老实说，这方面还需要做更多的研究。这方面也需要进行更多的对话。就像我们总是认为心理健康完全源于我们的选择，或者它是生物学的，但我们的环境有很多方面，包括我们约会的人，我们与之有浪漫关系的人，整个社会过程，与之相关的方方面面，确实对情感和心理产生了非常深远的影响。所以我希望你学到了一些东西。
I hope that this is helpful. I hope that you can apply it to your own life. And if there is someone who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. as always, please feel free as well to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening, if you feel cool to do so, it helps this show grow. Big shout out to Charlotte, who left me the nicest review on Apple Podcasts. Charlotte, thank you if you are listening to this. It made me super emotional.
我希望这有所帮助。我希望你能将它应用到你自己的生活中。如果有谁需要听这一集，请随时分享给他们。一如既往，如果你愿意的话，也请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，这有助于这个节目的成长。向夏洛特大声喊话，她在Apple Podcasts上给我留下了最好的评价。夏洛特，如果你在听的话，谢谢你。这让我非常感动。
I read every single one of them. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have a comment, if you have a query, if you have thoughts, please feel free to follow me at that psychology podcast. Reach out to me over there. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
我阅读了每一个评论。如果你有剧集建议，如果你有评论，如果你有疑问，如果你有想法，请随时在That Psychology Podcast关注我。在那里联系我。一如既往，我们下周将带着另一集回归。在《回顾过去》播客中。1979年，对我和说那是对我来说一个重要的时刻。84对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。收听《回顾过去》在iHeartRadio应用，Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人卡尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难成长》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你正在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大队来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《百分之二》。也就是iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。